So Dr Peterson,
you talking about this idea of ending
unnecessary suffering and this idea of
committing one's life to that at a
minimum,
I mean that's the minimum thing that you
could do.
A lot of students,
I think accept that premise and view
what they're doing as trying to
eliminate or reduce unnecessary
suffering and they see activism or other
forms of direct service as fulfilling
that goal.
Do you simply disagree with like the
content of what they think the tactic
that they are using to end unnecessary
suffering?
Or do you think that their motives or
their intentions are not even the same
as yours
to public?
You know,
there's,
there's this old saying from the,
from the new testament about not praying
in public.
Right?
And the idea is that if you're going to
commune for the higher good,
you should do it in private because
otherwise you're warping your ethic in
some sense by demonstrating how virtuous
you virtuous you are to the world.
It's like,
you know,
you go out there with a stick and a sign
on it that says I'm against poverty.
It's like,
yeah,
no kidding.
That's really like for poverty,
poverty,
so it's,
it's,
it's an abdication of responsibility
with the mask of social virtue and you
want to solve difficult problems.
You've figured out how to get along with
your brother,
the one you've been fighting with for
five years,
or see if you can staple your family
back together,
see if you can stop fighting with your
girlfriend and have a relationship that
lasts for more than two weeks.
You know,
it's like there are things that you
should be doing in the confines of your
own life that are private and humble,
that would,
would,
that would constitute genuine
accomplishments and those are the things
that you should attend to.
And no one's gonna come along and say,
hey,
you know,
good job,
you're,
you're changing the world because it's
private,
but it's real and people don't do that.
And so no,
I don't.
I don't trust the activist.
I don't trust the activist ethos at all.
I think.
I think everything about it is,
is superficial and,
and trendy and,
and too easy.
And and at the externalizes the blame,
the evil is always elsewhere,
which is a dreadful mistake to make
because the evil isn't elsewhere.
That's,
that's the thing that you understand
when you're wise is the evil is not
elsewhere,
it's you because you're not everything
you could be.
And so you know,
you should work on that before going in
and telling someone else that maybe
they're not who they should be.
So I think it's,
you know,
so I don't buy it.
It's too easy.
It's far too easy and it's too public
and it's too self congratulatory.
And then there's the murderous like
Marxist element,
which I'm always often inclined to
mention.
So certainly I think you've identified
certain causes where the public element
or the self congratulatory time to do
good.
Could it be harmful?
But do you think there are cases,
for instance,
I'm thinking of policy influencing
policy and being a policymaker.
It seems something like that public
policy could be used to eliminate some
unnecessary suffering but would involve
a more public domain.
Something where you are trying to
attract followers,
trying to attract praise from other
people.
Look,
if you,
if you've established yourself in the
world as a credible human being and
people are asking you to enter public
service because of your accomplishments,
then it's time to do it right,
but before that it's a little on the
premature side and if you're just
setting your for self forward as an
Avatar of an idea of an ideology,
then there's nothing to you except I
think of it as the chattering of various
forms of demons.
It's like you're not helpful and if you.
If you look,
you want to think,
okay,
are you fit to lead?
Let's,
let's put it that way.
Okay.
First of all,
do you know where you're going?
Because that's actually one of the
hallmarks of a leader.
Leader knows where he's going and maybe
other people are also interested in
going that way,
but the leaders I've met have carved
themselves out a personal vision,
right?
It's not some,
it's not some cookie cutter ideological
solution to the ills of the planet.
They've done a detailed analysis,
right?
They know what they're talking about and
they're usually people.
Well,
they've had a successful relationship,
they've had a successful family,
they have a couple of degrees,
they've established a business like
they've made themselves credible in five
or six dimensions.
Well then maybe you know enough about
the world to dare to mess with its
internal mechanisms and if you,
if you don't have that kind of in depth
knowledge,
then you should.
You shouldn't.
You should know more work on the
economic systems of Western
civilization.
Then you should try to adjust the
electronic systems of your automobile
because the latter is far less complex
than the former.
So of course there's utility in policy
formulation and in,
in government service,
and then all of those sorts of things.
But you have to.
You have to have transformed yourself at
least to some degree,
into someone who's actually competent
before you should even dare to do such
things.
You think,
well,
I have read some marks and now I know
how to change the world.
That that's a very bad idea because the
probability that you're going to take
something complex that doesn't work too
badly and fix it with your idiotic
intervention is zero.
Hmm.
Well put.